this room represents some of the women
that and and for me I'm seeing the women
that I would want to be with a lot of
beautiful women in that room yeah yeah
when you attach the attitude or attach
all of them I'm like I'm a guest speaker
I shouldn't be getting this energy but I
will give the energy back and because
and because they're giving all of that
energy it just makes you just want to
just send it right back and you send it
back in such a way that it was like Wow
and they feel it inside because yes
nobody wants to marry you because we
don't want to deal with this and me as a
man I would rather be like I'd rather be
a 47 year old man that's got my stuff
together with no kids and no baby mama